[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue je suis très
heureux de vous retrouver pour le 7-8
europe le magazine européen de la
rédaction de tv 78 au programme de ce
nouveau numéro une structure publique
pour prévenir et former les populations
aux risques d'inondations en
ile-de-france financé en partie par les
fonds structurels européens épicène
sensibilise des acteurs en vue de
diffuser ensuite les bonnes pratiques
si aucune date ne peut être fixée
formellement l'arrivée d'une crue
majeure en ile-de-france s'est quant à
elle certaines confinement en france en
irlande ou encore au pays de galles
couvre-feu presque partout l'europe
adoptent de nouvelles mesures sanitaires
pour contrer l'épidémie de lakovic 19
les dirigeants étaient réunis pour un
conseil européen spécial ce jeudi 29
novembre sujet majeur pour l'avenir de
l'europe la cyber sécurité était le
thème principal d'une rencontre
organisée à paris entre différents
acteurs du secteur
invité par de l'événement la commissaire
européenne maria gabriel nous lui avons
posé trois questions sur cette
thématique essentielle pour la
souveraineté technologique et numérique
du vieux continent
[Musique]
c'est une certitude mais connu des
habitants la région ile de france est
pourtant menacé tous les ans par les
crues éventuelles de ses fleuves la
seine et la marne l'inondation est même
le premier risque naturel majeur pour la
région près de 900 mille personnes
vivent dans une zone inondable c'est
pour anticiper ce danger que le service
public
et pis elle dispense des formations et
des ateliers à destination de tous les
publics
ce projet bénéficie des financements des
fonds structurels européens sa mission
préparer et informer pour le jour j
reportage lors d'une session s quelle
game à paris ces événements ont plongé
paris sous les eaux c'est le scénario du
pire tant redouté par les pouvoirs
publics
paris et sa région les pieds dans l'eau
des centaines de milliers de franciliens
inondées et paniquer et toute l'île de
france paralysée ce qui relève encore de
la fiction pourrait devenir un jour
réalité et c'est pour éviter cette
catastrophe que la structure épicène
sensibilise le grand public aux risques
d'inondations en ile de france
ce jour là les participants doivent
collaborer pour résoudre en moins d'une
heure un escape game
il vous reste coi com
leur mission du jour échappés ensemble à
la crue centennale de 2072 c'était assez
amusant c'était assez stressant aussi
avec le temps qui défile la lumière qui
s'éteint régulièrement cette manière
beaucoup plus intéressant de faire
passer des informations parce qu'on fait
en s'amusant et son côté potentiellement
anxiogène
alors je dis a pas d'un côté stressant
parce que ça le fait bien mais sans côté
anxiogène du fait que c'est une
inondation et tous à la vidéo de mise en
situation est assez sympa donc c'est pas
mal que faire avant pendant et après une
crue dans une région plus d'un sondé sur
trois pense ne pas être exposés aux
risques d'inondations épicène se donne
pour objectif de former des acteurs
locaux
charge à eux ensuite de diffuser les
bonnes pratiques
on a quand même des gens qui connaissent
certaines choses mais qui sont toujours
en demande justement de savoir comment
transmettre le problème quand nous on
est spécialiste voilà hydrologue des
spécialistes du risque inondation le
plus important pour nous c'est de bien
communiquer c'est bien former les gens
c'est bien les sensibiliser et du coup
ce mode unis sert à ça huit cent
cinquante mille personnes et 620 mille
emplois installé en zone inondable les
enjeux sont colossaux pour la région
capitale le territoire habitué des
inondations avec deux crues importantes
en moins de cinq ans en juin 2016 le
niveau de la seine avait atteint six
mètres 10 bien loin encore de la crue
historique de 1910 et un pic à 8 mètres
62e qui avaient alors bloqué la capitale
pendant plusieurs jours c'est un risque
qui est inéluctable c'est un phénomène
qui séculaire enfin millénaire qui s'est
déjà passé qui se reproduira de toute
façon il faut que les gens s'y prépare
il faut que les gens soient productifs
par rapport à ça elles n'attendent pas
ne se laisse pas surprendre entre
guillemets notamment en ile-de-france où
le risque est prévisible lhomond par
général d'un mètre à un mètre cinquante
par jour
donc on a à peu près en général deux à
trois jours pour se préparer
selon une récente étude internationale
une crue égale à celle de 1910 pourrait
produire jusqu'à 30 milliards d'euros de
dégâts et sinistré jusqu'à 5 millions de
franciliens
et s'il ya bien un risque qui impacte la
vie des européens depuis huit mois a
désormais c'est celui du coronavirus la
triste
bardet 260 mille morts vient d'être
franchie en europe le continent redevenu
à la faveur de l'automne l'épicentre
mondial de la crise sanitaire pour faire
face à la deuxième vague et limitée le
nombre de morts les pays ont adopté de
nouvelles mesures à l'instar de la
france l'irlande et le pays de galles en
décrété aussi un nouveau confinement de
leur population
l'allemagne elle a décidé de l'entrée en
vigueur d'un confinement partiel et plus
allégé à partir du 2 novembre et pour
quatre semaines dans la plupart des
autres pays européens des couvre-feux
sont mises en place et ce dès 18h par
exemple en italie une mesure qui a
entraîné des manifestations exception
européenne la suède elle n'impose
toujours pas de mesures strictes à sa
population le port du masque n'y est pas
recommandé notamment ces mesures dans la
plupart des pays européens ont un impact
évidemment sur les possibilités de
voyage et de déplacements pour connaître
les restrictions mises en place et les
recommandations faites aux voyageurs
dans les pays vous pouvez toujours
consulter le site internet de la
commission européenne reopen point
europa.eu toujours pour contrer à cette
deuxième vague les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des 27 pays membres se sont
mis d'accord il y a quelques jours sur
le déblocage de plus de 200 millions
d'euros pour le transfert de patients
entre les pays et la mise à disposition
aussi de données commune sur l'avancée
du virus les chefs d'état ont enfin
apporté leur soutien à la france après
l'attaqué terroriste survenue à nice je
voudrais commencer notre réunion part
exprimé je pense pour le faire au nom de
l'ensemble des collègues la solidarité
européenne exprimait aussi aux
solidarités notre support face à des
attaques terroristes rachdi qui à
nouveau ont été menées il s'agit
valeurs démocratiques ça a été libéré il
s'agit de l'état de droit et je pense
pouvoir dire en votre nom à tous que
nous sommes une idée va sembler pour
défendre ces valeurs qui doit sans qui
nous unissent que s'est il passé dans le
reste de l'actualité européenne un prix
décerné par le parlement européen pour
l'opposition en biélorusse les priorités
de l'union européenne pour 2021 et des
européens davantage préoccupés par la
situation économique du continent c'est
l'actualité européenne en brève
un hommage et un silence le parlement
européen de bruxelles debout pour saluer
la mémoire de samuel patil enseignants
français tués dans les yvelines le 16
octobre dernier david sassoli le
président du parlement européen a
insisté dans sa déclaration sur le rôle
majeur joué par l'enseignement
laterrière ses combats par l'éducation
par l'enseignement auquel se mêlent
petit corps et y est tel qu'il est
pratiqué un enseignement bienveillant et
critique ouvert sur la société sur
l'autre prenant les dialogues et la
connaissance s'est lui aussi pour son
action l'opposition bélarusse est vu
décerner le prix sakharov 2020 par le
parlement européen
attribué depuis 1988 ce prix récompense
des personnes ou organisations qui
agissent en faveur des libertés
fondamentales l'opposition bélarusse est
durement réprimée pour contester depuis
trois mois les résultats des élections
présidentielle et la réélection
d'alexandre loukachenko
après une année et 2020 marquée par la
crise sanitaire et économique l'année
2000 21 sera telle celle de la relance
politique la commission européenne
l'espère elle vient de dévoiler son
programme de travail pour l'an prochain
parmi ses priorités le pacte vert pour
l'europe qui vise à réduire d'ici dix
ans de 55 % les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre du continent la commission
souhaite aussi accélérer sur la question
du numérique ou encore la mise en place
d'un socle européen des droits sociaux
des préoccupations d'abord économique
selon la dernière étude européenne sur
l'opinion publique
eurobaromètre les citoyens européens
s'inquiètent pour 35% d'entre eux de la
situation économique du continent
deuxième sujet d'intérêt pour les
finances publiques des états membres à
égalité à 23% avec l'immigration en
france ces deux sujets sont supplantées
par l'environnement et le changement
climatique qui préoccupe 28% des
personnes interrogées l'actualité
européenne aussi marquée par un regain
des tensions avec la turquie suite aux
déclarations du président henri tilhet
père
dogan sur la santé mentale des manuels
macron le président français qui a reçu
le soutien de ses homologues
continentaux une nouvelle opposition
diplomatique qui surgit après les
tensions déjà acté sur l'accès aux eaux
en méditerranée sur la confrontation
territoriale en cours entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan la pologne enfin limites
de son côté à nouveau le droit à
l'avortement la cour constitutionnelle
de varsovie a notamment jugé contraire à
la loi
l interruption volontaire de grossesse
pour les femmes enceintes de foetus
souffrant de malformations même grave
irréversible avec cette nouvelle
décision l'avortement est presque rendu
impossible en pologne
à noter qu'au sein de l'union européenne
seuls malte dispose d'une politique
encore plus restrictive en la matière
puisque olivier y est totalement
interdite sur place
[Musique]
la deuxième édition de la cyber week
paris sibérie qui se tenait récemment à
la maison de la chimie
au programme rencontres et échanges
entre les différents acteurs du secteur
de la cybersécurité parmi les invités la
commissaire européenne maria gabriel en
charge de l'innovation et de la
recherche
avec elle nous avons fait le point sur
la filière cb cybersécurité et le
travail effectué entre lieux et les
collectivités territoriales une
interview recueillie par nicolas d'andré
[Musique]
la barbe la cyber sécurité il est
vraiment au fondement de ce qu'on
voudrait réussir comme une europe adapté
à la transformation numérique
[Musique]
cela concerne nos données personnelles
cela concerne la sécurité de nos
services de nos produits cela concerne
tout simplement la sécurité de notre
économie et de notre société
nous avons besoin d'experts aujourd'hui
il manque 300 mille experts en
cybersécurité comment attirer la
jeunesse
je crois que si on trouve des méthodes
adaptées pour chaque âge parce que ce
n'est pas la même la même chose aux
primaires que dans l'université de
montrer tout simplement l'extraordinaire
diversité des métiers de cyber on a plus
de chances d'avoir des jeunes
nous avons besoin de nos enseignants les
enseignants qu'ils puissent parler les
métiers de l'incident sécurité qu'ils
puissent avoir accès à des formations en
ce moment nous avons quarante et une
alliance européenne les universités
c'est notre grande initiative pour
l'espace européen de l'éducation qui
doit être réalisé d'ici 2025
[Musique]
collectivités territoriales entend rôle
fondamental à jouer je ne me réjouis que
dans le domaine de la recherche de
l'innovation de l'éducation de la
culture pour la première fois nous avons
décidé ensemble avec le comité des
régions de faire un plan d'action
conjoint pour les deux prochaines années
pour nous le rôle des régions sera
fondamental et pour la transformation
numérique et pour la nécessité d'avoir
plus de personnes qui ont les
compétences numériques de base et
avancées nécessaires pour créer des
entreprises pour créer des start up pour
permettre à nos services administratifs
électronique d'être au plus haut point
de 14 à 28 jours le congé paternité va
doubler bientôt en france une bonne
nouvelle pour lutter notamment contre
les discriminations à l'embauché avec
cet allongement où se situe désormais la
france comparée à ses voisins européens
éléments de réponse avec olivier jeanne
l'ex responsable du centre d'information
europe direct de saint germain en laye
les pays nordiques sont les plus
généreux
la norvège est le premier pays au monde
à avoir instauré le congé paternité
il dure de dix à trente neuf semaines le
père et la mère peuvent se répartir les
semaines et choisir de percevoir 100 %
ou 80% de leur salaire selon la durée du
congé au total à la naissance de leur
enfant les parents disposent de 59
semaines de congés dix semaines pour la
mer dix semaines pour le père et le
reste a partagé en suède comme la mère
le père est autorisé à prendre jusqu'à
480 jours de congés payés à hauteur de
80% du salaire
en finlande le jeune père bénéficie de
50 qu'elle jours de congés payés
la mère a le droit à 105 jours s'ajoute
au congé paternité 26 semaines de congé
parental à partager le danemark se
montre également généreux le père peut
prendre deux semaines de congés payés
intégralement la mer elle dispose de 18
semaines auxquelles s'ajoutent 32
semaines payé 100% de leur salaire à se
répartir en allemagne pas de congé
paternité mais le père a le droit de
prendre un congé parental de 14 mois
maximum à partager avec la mer le congé
maternité est lui de 14 semaines dont
huit semaines après la naissance du bébé
en espagne le père bénéficie de huit
semaines de congés payés en intégralité
et d'ici 2021 il aura même droit à 15
semaines de congé paternité soit autant
que la mère et pour terminer en slovénie
c'est 30 jours mais les parents ont
droit à congé parental de 260 jours en
bulgarie
le père a le droit à quinze jours de
congés payés
quatre cent dix jours pour la mer et
enfin en italie et en grèce le père
dispose de deux jours de congé paternité
contre cinq mois pour la mère est dit
cette semaine en grèce c'est la fin du
set 8 europe vous pouvez retrouver
évidemment tous ces modules un reportage
sur le site de tv 78 tv 70 points comme
ou les réseaux sociaux on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro du 7-8
europe a très vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le